from face mask to serum's promising
glass skin it's hard to avoid Korean
beauty products if you walk down a
beauty aisle right here in the United
States the beauty industry in South
Korea is expected to be worth nearly 14
billion dollars by 2027 but South Korea
is also considered the plastic surgery
capital of the world unrealistic body
standards are leading many women to go
to extremes Elise Hughes saw these
Trends Collide while she was NPR sole
bureau chief for nearly four years she's
got a new book out it is called Flawless
lessons and looks and culture from the K
Beauty Capital it examines how those
issues intersect with technology and how
the impact it is having on women and men
around the world Elise Hugh is joining
us here good morning good morning
congratulations on the book so listen I
my wife and I had a layover in Seoul
coming back from Thailand this summer
and somebody said to us but did you go
for a little nip talking and I was like
what are you talking about because even
just the appearance of stopping over in
South Korea for 24 hours leads people to
wonder that you're getting work done
what are the expectations for shape for
size for beauty in South Korea they're
rather specific and I was really thrown
by this when I first got to Seoul I got
there and instantly I was flooded with
images of the ideal Korean woman and
it's long luxurious hair it's that
porcelain skin it's Big Bright Eyes
great legs great legs and a thinness
that I had never seen before when I went
shopping I learned about free size but
free size as I write is not free free
size is a U.S size two yeah and so very
immediately I felt unwelcome you said
eight is considered plus size that's
right that's right I started yelling
about you big size big size yeah it's
very unwelcoming when you're walking up
and down the street and shopkeepers are
outside going large size large size you
know you say in your book Beauty matters
more in Korea than any other place on
Earth the entire country small enough to
fit in between LA and San Francisco
that's how small it is yet the beauty
industry there is huge and you say when
do we get to the place where we just
need to feel flawed but worthy yeah in
South Korea Korea which is now the
world's third largest cosmetics in skin
care exporter and this is a country
again that's rather small but really
outsized when it comes to exporting
Beauty
um there was this concept that I learned
called lookism so add to racism and
sexism
appearance-based discrimination called
lookism and so passport photos would get
photoshopped by default yeah headshots
were required on resumes even for
accounting jobs or government jobs and
parents would gift plastic surgery to
their High School grads because of this
expectation that you look good and that
you work hard to look Elise you talk
about babies having facials so where do
we draw the line on improving ourselves
especially when medicine can really do
the trick for you that was one of the
big animating questions of the book
because so often when I had some sort of
blemish or I have freckles which is
really frowned upon in South Korea and
so a lot of folks would say freckles we
can remove that like if you can fix the
problem why wouldn't you yes so it was a
lot of supply of a solution driving
demand and I think we see that with
technology so I mean these lessons from
from Korea they impact our culture here
people buy these products or the
exporting so how does one resist how do
you raise daughters in this world and
you have daughters no matter yes exactly
one of the reasons I wrote this book is
because I had two of my daughters in
Seoul and my three-year-old was asked
whether she had eyelash extensions whoa
very very young and that's because of
the logic that you do the work to look
good and so what I'm really trying to do
is focus on two ideas one is body
neutrality which is there are no good
bodies or bad bodies they are bodies and
our bodies can be celebrated for what
they can do the other is this idea of
centralism which is that bodies can be
celebrated for what they feel and it
sounds really great in theory but it's
very difficult in practice yeah yeah
yeah I love that idea body neutrality I
do too and I love that you're sharing
that message with your daughters I'm
taking the
this book is called Flawless very well
it is on sale now wherever you like to
buy your books it's an Incredible Book
congratulations again thank you it's a
beautiful cover although maybe we
shouldn't say that